la bombe avant de vous parler de ça je
vais vous demander de vous prêter à un
petit exercice
donc je vous demander de fermer les yeux
de laisser partir votre imagination et
d'écouter quelques mots allez-y fermer
les yeux
athome atomique nucléaires radioactifs
tchernobyl fukushima
allez-y ouvrez les yeux alors je suis
sûr que certains d'entre vous ont
imaginé des belles centrale avec de la
vapeur d'eau qui montent dans le ciel
bleu ou plus probablement des images un
peu plus sinistres un peu plus sombre
une catastrophe en espèces de nuages
tout noirs pleins de matériaux
radioactifs
mais quels que soient ces images que
vous avez en tête ces sujets sont
malheureusement d'actualité et à peine
deux mois nous avons marqué les dix les
30 ans de la catastrophe de tchernobyl
et en l'espace de quelques semaines les
cinq ans de fukushima peut-être que
certains d'entre vous se rappellent
d'autres n'étaient pas encore là moi
j'avais six ans lors de la catastrophe
de tchernobyl je me souviens vaguement
d'avoir entendu à la radio quelque chose
sur un accident mais c'était très très
loin et elle secret était bien gardé mon
ex union soviétique
par contre si on accélère le temps un
peu en 2011
personne n'a pu échapper à ces images on
a été inondé de photos en quelques
heures sur tous les réseaux sur tous les
écrans et donc ça va c'est ça qui passe
le contrôle parental
la jolie photo d'une explosion dans un
réacteur nucléaire
personne n'a pu échapper personne n'a pu
daigné l'impact de cette catastrophe
personne n'a pu le dénigrer on a tous vu
des images de personnes évacuées à plus
de cent mille personnes évacuées dans un
rayon de 30 km autour de cette centrale
on a vu des images de travailleurs en
combinaison avec des conteurs de
radioactivité des masques à gaz
c'est très effrayant personne ne peut
dénier l'impact non seulement sur la
communauté locale mais aussi sur le
japon tous les réacteurs toutes les
centrales ont été harry
et il y en a qu'une qui a été qui est en
opération actuellement on ne peut pas
dénier le l'impact sur le monde les
politiques énergétiques d'autres pays la
transition énergétique en france en
allemagne aux états unis et pourquoi est
ce que je vous raconte tout ça parce que
malgré le fait que cet impact et étaient
si forts malgré le la peur la panique
après cinq ans la plupart des sites
une grande partie de la zone contaminée
a été nettoyé la plupart des des
personnes évacuées ont été autorisées à
revenir chez elle même s'ils ne sont pas
encore revenus des équipes de recherches
internationales comme la mienne peuvent
se rendre sur le site quotidiennement
ici on est à peu près 50 mètres des
réacteurs
il ya 6000 personnes qui travaillent sur
le site 24 heures sur 24 pour tout
nettoyer pour s'assurer que c'est
sécurisé donc il ya beaucoup d'efforts
pour pour pouvoir aller au delà de cette
catastrophe
malheureusement ou heureusement donc mon
équipe n'a pas participé à cet effort
mais nos recherches étaient en relation
avec cet effort de décontamination de
nettoyage parce que nous travaillons à
l'époque nous travaillons toujours
depuis huit ans au développement d'un
nouveau traitement pour décontaminer les
personnes éventuellement contaminés aux
radionucléides parce que un des grands
risques d'une catastrophe nucléaire
c'est ça la contamination en
radionucléides
qu'est ce que ce que sont les
radionucléides ce sont ces éléments
radioactifs dans le tableau périodique
qui sont impliqués dans le cycle du
nucléaire on entend beaucoup parler du
césium de l'yonne on a entendu beaucoup
parler ces éléments après fukushima on a
moins entendu parler des métaux lourds
radioactifs qui participent au cycle
nucléaire
les actinides comme l'uranium le
plutonium et donc ce sont ces métaux sur
lesquels nous travaillons
une fois que que la dissémination de ces
méthodes se passe une fois qu'ils sont
incorporées dans l'organisme soit par
inhalation par ingestion ou à travers
des blessures est très difficile de s'en
débarrasser ils vont se fixer sur les
eaux dans le foie dans les reins
et vont causer beaucoup de dégâts on va
voir une hausse était tout cancer et
d'autres dégâts et donc il faut
développer une stratégie pour pouvoir
s'en débarrasser pour pouvoir les
éliminer
et cette stratégie cela la chélation
c'est pas un nouveau concept la
chélation ça existe depuis très
longtemps
par contre le l'intérêt de nos de nos
recherches c'est de pouvoir montrer
qu'on arrive à cibler spécifiquement ces
métaux et pas par exemple le faire qui
est un métal essentielles ou le zinc ce
qui deviendra toxiques sion de faire
aussi et donc pour ça on doit répondre à
des critères de chimie de coordination
très spécifique développer des molécules
qui vont agir comme des des pinces une
pince de crabe qui va trouver ce métal
dans l'organisme former un complexe
comme une petite bulle qui va alors être
excrété plus facilement et donc on se
débarrasse de ces métaux radioactifs
la sélection de la molécule c'était la
première étape c'était il ya huit ans
mais en fait le plus gros du travail
c'est de passer de cette molécule à un
médicament dont quelque chose qui
ressemble à ça que les gens pourraient
prendre
utilisez donc on doit montrer
l'efficacité de cette molécule dans
l'organisme
on doit comprendre son devenir dans
si ça ça pharmacologie sa toxicologie
donc ça ça ça demande énormément
d'études in vitro même si in vivo chez
l'animal donc plusieurs espèces animales
et une fois qu'on a compris ça donc on a
appris à peu près six ans 15 millions de
dollars une énorme équipe nous avons la
chance d'être considérés par la food and
drug administration aux états unis donc
c'est l'équivalent de l' agence du
médicament qui nous autorise maintenant
à procéder à des essais cliniques
donc rassurez vous les essais cliniques
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on va contaminer
les gens au plutonium juste pour essayer
notre médicament juste pour partie ça
marche
les essais cliniques sont des essais de
sécurité des essais de phase 1 on va
regarder le devenir la pharmacologie de
cette molécule chez lui et chez des
êtres humains enfin une fois qu'on a
compris ce métabolisme
on peut le comparer nos données dans les
espèces animales et on peut alors
déterminer comment administrer ce
médicament à des humains donc à quelle
dose
combien de fois par jour pendant combien
de temps
donc c'est un succès puisque met sur la
voie d'aboutir un vrai traitement pour
décontaminer les personnes contaminés au
plutonium
mais ce n'est qu'une infime partie une
infime pièces du puzzle de la réponse à
cette catastrophe
pourquoi parce qu'il faut pouvoir le
distribuer et par exemple ici je vous
montre une gélule donc imaginez la
catastrophe nucléaire des centaines de
milliers de personnes qui doivent être
évacués on va pas leur distribuer des
sourire il leur dira les y injecter vous
parce que ça va vous aider à vous des
contaminés peuvent être blessés donc il
faut pouvoir penser au paquet qu'on va
pouvoir leur donner à prendre expliqué
comment utiliser si je sais j'ai lu les
ouvrir écrasez la poudre dans du yaourt
pour le donner aux enfants
donc il ya beaucoup de choses à faire
mais au-delà de ça du nucléaire c'est
très effrayant la contamination
radioactive c'est ça me panique mais
rappelez vous qu avant tout fukushima ce
n'est pas un accident nucléaire
seulement c'est le plus un des plus
grands tremblements de terre au japon un
des plus grandes sont amis donc voilà
l'infrastructure après cet accident
et cette photo a été prise il ya un peu
plus d'un an dont quatre ans après
l'accident dans la zone contaminée
voilà une pêcherie qui se situe quelques
kilomètres au sud
donc tout est détruit toute
l'infrastructure et endommagé les routes
endommagées les gens doivent partir de
chez eux et un stress psychologique pour
dans l'évacuation pour se reconstruire
une vie comprendre ce qui nous arrive
mais maintenant 5 ans plus tard
maintenant que cette zone est nettoyé
comment convaincre ces personnes de
revenir comment les convaincre de
revenir avec leur enfant s'il n'y a pas
d'école si les professeurs ne sont pas
revenus
si le supermarché ma part ouvert comment
leur démontrer que cette zone est et
sécurisée qui a pu le risque de
contamination ce risque d'exposition aux
radiations
il faut tout un travail d'éducation si
vous vous promenez maintenant dans la
préfecture de fukushima à tous les coins
de rue il ya des dosimètres donc c'est
ces compteurs ou donne une idée du taux
de radiation ambiant à tous les coins de
rue
ici vous pouvez voir un chiffre un
nombre 0 point 192 micro sievert par
heure qu'est ce que ça veut dire comment
est ce que vous pouvez comprendre ça si
vous n'avez pas été informé si on ne
vous a pas expliqué ce que c'est que la
radiation si on ne nous a pas expliqué
ce que le taux naturel de radiation ce
qui provient du sol des rayons cosmiques
si vous mettez cette même machine à
denver dans l'état du colorado aux états
unis qui en altitude et qui a un taux de
de particules radioactives dans le sol
dans la terre beaucoup plus élevé ce
chiffre va être dix fois plus élevée et
il n'y a pas eu d'accident nucléaire à
denver et pourtant c'est le taux de
radiation ambiant donc comment expliquer
ça aux mamans qui vont retourner avec
leurs enfants que ce chiffre il faut
qu'elle s'y habitue qu'elle comprenne
que c'est toujours là que si pas si par
exemple ça ça monte ça veut dire qu'il
ya un problème mais si on est à ce
niveau là il n'y a aucun problème donc
ça fait partie de l'information de
l'éducation
parce que soyons réalistes ce concept de
pouvoir répondre à une catastrophe
ce concept d'être résilient de fonder
une communauté qui peut rebondir après
le traumatisme in europe innova pas
partir je vous introduit le concept de
résilience ici c'est un concept qui a
emprunté à la physique on parle de
résilience des métaux pour des métaux
qui ont été déformés et qui sont
capables de reprendre leur structure
originale dans le contexte de la
communauté à une communautés résilientes
c'est une communauté qui a pas qu'il est
capable de rebondir après le traumatisme
qui est capable de retrouver un
fonctionnement normal
donc il ya une catastrophe on peut y
répondre on peut informer les personnes
on peut nettoyer mais ça c'est la carte
de centrales nucléaires dans le monde
super imposé superposer une carte
sismique donc on a encore pas mal de
centrales nucléaires dans des zones
sismiques
ça veut dire qu'il ya un très grand
risque mais ça veut aussi dire qu'il n'y
a pas de risque zéro
la possibilité d'un accident dans le
futur elle est là et donc il faut
pouvoir apprendre de ce qui s'est passé
et le transformer en quelque chose
un indu des matériaux des outils que
l'on peut donner aux communautés pour
qu'elles puissent répondre plus
facilement plus rapidement plus
précisément
futur certains d'entre vous vont dire
mais pourquoi ne démantèle pas sa
centrale nucléaire on n'a pas vraiment
besoin
moi j'ai grandi en france après
tchernobyl
une élève studieuse j'ai appris que des
trois quarts de l'électricité en france
et est produite grâce au nucléaire que
la france était l'un des pays les plus
avancés dans le nucléaire le japon voici
donc la plupart la majorité une grande
majorité de l'exciter au japon et est
produite avec le nucléaire
si on démantèle ses centrales
d'accord il ya plus de risque radioactif
mais ce qu'on est prêt à sacrifier autre
chose est ce qu'on est prêt à sacrifier
notre demande en énergie vous voyez
cette carte la lumière mais l'énergie
ses passions la lumière l'énergie c'est
tous ces gadgets
ces ordinateurs ses téléphones portables
les tablettes les appareils ménagers les
moyens de transport on en a besoin de
l'énergie
ce besoin s'accroît continuellement est
ce que quelqu'un est prêt à sacrifier
ses 8 heures devant l'écran d'ordinateur
chaque jour pour 6h 5h pour avoir moins
besoin d'énergie est ce qu'on est
capable de développer de nouvelles
technologies pour répondre à ce besoin
d'énergie oui on est en train on est en
train de développer les énergies
renouvelables l'énergie solaire les
cellules photovoltaïques
mais bon c est ce qu il ya dans ces
cellules photovoltaïques dans les
nouvelles batteries qu'est-ce qu'il ya
des métaux rares sont pas des métaux
radioactifs ne sont quand même des
métaux toxiques se sont une ressource
qu'il faut extraire de la terre donc
comment faire pour pouvoir répondre à
ses besoins sans avoir une réaction de
panique
en apprenant ce qui s'est passé je vais
faire une petite digression ici parce
que je faisais je vous ai dit est ce que
vous êtes prêt à vous sacrifier à
sacrifier votre temps d'écran c'est
difficile à imaginer - ya trente ans on
n'avait pas tous téléphones portables
donc on pouvait vivre sans mais
maintenant c'est un peu plus difficile
moi je viens californie donc il ya une
autre ressource qui est un peu un peu
moins du luxe que l'énergie c'est une
ressource vraiment fondamental à la
survie de notre espèce
ces lots on a plus d'eau en sachet
stress depuis quelques années à tel
point que l'année dernière le
le gouverneur de l'état a déclaré l'état
d'alerté il a ordonné des restrictions
d'eau qu'est ce que ça veut dire des
restrictions d'eau ça veut dire que vous
rentrez chez vous le prendre huit
douches par semaine on en prend six au
lieu de passer quatre minutes sous la
douche on passe trois minutes au lieu de
donner un bain à ses enfants
lundi non moment-là barbillons lui lave
pas les cheveux il faut mieux les sous
la douche ça irait plus vite
c'est très difficile de sacrifier sa
ressource de de changer ses habitudes de
changer son comportement mais c'est
nécessaire
en un an cette année la californie les
la population de la californie a réussi
à réduire de 25 % de sa consommation
d'eau par le changement de comportement
donc c'est possible c'est difficile mais
c'est possible
donc revenons en au thème de ces
présentations les 7 milliards de défis
il ya beaucoup de défis à relever pour
pouvoir continuer à survivre sur cette
planète
mais moi je j'espère que mes enfants
n'auront jamais à se soucier du manque
d'eau ou du manque d'énergie et j'espère
que personne n'aurait jamais utilisé ce
traitement que nous développons vraiment
même si le butin d'un médicament ces
deux c'est déjà quelque chose mais
vraiment on espère que personne ne
l'utilisera mais par contre ce que
j'espère c'est que tout le monde va
prendre conscience de cet effort qui
nécessaire cet effort qui est nécessaire
pour aller au delà de la catastrophe se
prépare et modifier son comportement
pour pouvoir répondre plus facilement si
la catastrophe arrive les petits ennuis
ou une grosse catastrophe ils vont
pouvoir être prêt à répondre il faut
pouvoir encourager la science le
développement de nouvelles technologies
mais il faut aussi pouvoir encourager
leur utilisation maîtrisée et vigilante
donc il faut faire attention et ça
j'espère que c'est un effort que tout le
monde est prêt à fournir un effort
individuel un effort collectif pour que
nous puissions tous faire partie de
sociétés qui sont de toujours plus
résiliente